bonsoir Michel j'ai fait bon voyage dans
l'espace-temps non je peux plus jamais
bon voyage maintenant je horreur des
voyages vous faisiez quoi un moment où
je vous ai demandé de venir dans cette
émission j'étais en train de rêver que
j'ai tremblais les gens qui devaient
applaudir et hurler dans toutes les
émissions de télé
alors
[Applaudissements]
qu'en Bouygues
publiquement nous aurions toute liberté
de parler de ce que nous voulions même
des affaires de Bouygues et comme toutes
les grandes affaires de l'immobilier ne
sont jamais très clairs je j'ai dit bah
on pourra peut-être parler aussi
d'affaires de construction ce que j'ai
fait bah oui il y a une maison de maçon
un pont de maçon une télé de M voilà pas
des saints de Vias ce qui est passé au
vidéographe et ça vous a coûté votre
réaction dès l'émission ils ont mis
combien de temps à vous virer après ça
je veux dire c'était un samedi soir et
vous envierez le lundi soir
le lait m'a téléphoné en hurlant sa
première fois que j'entendais quelqu'un
hurler comme ça j'ai cru j'ai hésité
entre la folie et le numéro répété dans
les dans les boîtes de marketing
américaine on vous apprend ce genre de
choses pour terroriser vos employés et
c'est
c'est bizarre et le lendemain il y a eu
le Télégramme ça pas duré longtemps vous
regrettez vous êtes fait virer après du
tout non pas du tout parce que je pense
que
travailler dans les conditions de
travail mes anciens confrères de TF1 je
leur ai pas supporté je l'ai plein pas
tous mais certains je les plains parce
qu'ils sont laissés grignoter certains
sont laissés complètement détruire de
l'intérieur je pense que il y a une
technique pour détruire les gens en les
surveillant à partir de là ils n'ont
plus le courage de partir et de dire
merde et je donc je l'ai échappé belle
parce que
je pense que j'aurais dit merde quand
même parce qu'au fond l'argent je m'en
fiche mais on sait jamais
faisant référence à ce que dit certaines
tribus primitives sur le fait que
lorsqu'on les films lorsqu'on les
photographies ça leur mangent l'âme vous
avez dit la télé bouffe la télé du
flamme
non non
ppdam de Bernard Montiel a été bouffée
par exemple ce qui est d'abord l'âme de
qui Bernard Montiel
est-ce que vous croyez que l'âme de
Jean-Pierre Foucault a été bouffé par
exemple
vous faites beaucoup rire avec l'âme des
empires il a une arme tout homme à une
arme oui non je crois il faut éteindre
du genre en tout homme à une arme oui
bah oui mais la thé quand même bouffée
et mettons 9 dixième il reste toujours
un petit quelque chose mais mais non
mais venir chez vous on peut perdre son
arbre mais mes copains m'ont tous dit
qu'est-ce que tu vas faire dans ce
mauvais lieu
c'est la première on peut pas encore
dire c'est un mauvais lieu non mais
c'est votre réputation j'ai une mauvaise
réputation c'est très très mauvaise
réputation on a fait pour s'entendre
c'est notre point commun c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que j'accepte vos
invitations parce que je préfère les
gens qui ont des réputations douteuses
comme
vous avez dit aussi qu'en tant quitte
l'antenne on perd une excitation
fabuleuse donc entre se laisser bouffer
là mais et perdre cette excitation
fabuleuse qu'est-ce qu'il faut choisir
dites-moi parce que moi je peux
m'arrêter ah non mais l'excitation moi
je trouve que c'est très mauvais c'est
comme prendre de la drogue je suppose
moi j'ai senti que on me l'a bouffait
mon âme j'en étais pas au point de
Jean-Pierre Foucault mais ça commençait
ça commence sacrée soirée quand même
si vous aviez le pouvoir de réorganiser
le paysage audiovisuel français imaginé
comme ça vous êtes ministre de la
télévision faites quoi première chose
que vous faites le lendemain matin
je propose la renationalisation de TF1
ben non parce que vous comprenez
maintenant on a l'Italie avec Berlusconi
on a vu ce que ça donne on aura bientôt
la France avec tapis vous savez ça quand
même oui quand il va se mettre d'accord
avec TF1 donc pas fait c'est clair mais
ça en prend le chemin ce qui est très
marrant c'est que depuis que vous êtes
parti plus personne prend de vrai risque
à la télévision
écoutez il y en a un on a dit que ça y
est parce qu'il a mis sa petite au bec
on a dit dans le monde que ça y est
Paula qui était allait trouver son
successeur c'est Michel fil là-bas
intervie 400 personnes en direct 400
jeunes ont chauffé à blanc là je tire
mon chapeau marqué dans la transgression
alors c'est plus léger mais Doc et
Difool sur sur Fun Radio ils ont fait
pas mal là non vous en pensez quoi de ça
vous bon moi je ne veux pas avoir
d'opinion là-dessus je pense que on doit
pas parler de sexe n'importe comment et
que
si je sais pas si c'est vrai si on a
expliqué en détail à une jeune fille ce
qui est la zoophilie
les détails n'étaient pas utiles dire ce
que c'est je trouve même un gamin de 8
ans aujourd'hui avec tout ce qui se
passe ils savent tout alors il faut leur
répondre
donner des détails non tout est dans la
manière les gros mots ça me gêne pas
mais le côté libidineux sous-entendu
machin comme j'entends c'est pas moi
l'autre jour j'ai vu par hasard
Philippe Bouvard en train de faire une
émission avec des gens qui racontent des
histoires genre histoire drôle [ __ ]
qu'on raconte à la fin des banquets
qu'on a un peu souple ces gens-là
étaient vraiment tous plus dégueulasse
les uns que les autres c'est
insupportable au fait pas supportable
c'est ça donc c'est vide
mais un truc qu'on est en commun c'est
qu'on ne partage pas le culte de Cyril
Collard dire que une époque où on
demande aux jeunes de mettre des
préservatifs la sanctification de Cyril
Collard vous choque beaucoup aussi
d'ailleurs j'ai lu dans le Globe que ça
choquait Glucksman aussi
moi j'ai pas vu le film mais j'ai lu le
livre alors ça m'a largement suffit j'ai
lu le livre personne savait qui c'était
je reçois beaucoup de bouquins et j'ai
vu ce livre avec ce style que je trouve
vulgaire et cette fameuse soi-disant
romantique où il passe il est
séropositifs et finalement avec sa
petite amie je suis désolé ça n'a rien
de romantique c'est dégueulasse et il y
a rien là-dedans qui qui avertit les
lecteurs jeunes qui va lui passer le
sida et qu'elle va en crever et non
seulement elle va il va lui passer mais
qu'elle même le passera enfin c'est
d'une inconscient c'est que tout ça on
en est fait un culte et c'est alors là
la vulgarité elle est totale
et c'est triste de voir tant de jeunes
qui sont là dira oui c'est rigolard vous
pensez que la société française est
décadente aujourd'hui là où je vois une
vraie décadence et que je vois pas le
relais
je pense c'est pas les jeunes qui vont
nous apporter le relais ils ont pas
justement si vous aviez 20 ans
aujourd'hui
vous essaierez essayeriez de mettre le
pied dans une entreprise pour même au
début gagner pas beaucoup et puis il
rentrait vous marcheriez dans la rue
avec les avec les manifestants je sais
pas moi c'est qu'à 20 ans j'ai abandonné
mes études en disant gagner ma vie ça
m'intéresse pas de venir
un bon bourgeois avec des diplômes ça
m'intéresse pas et ça plaisait pas ma
mère mais je l'ai fait quand même et je
suis parti travailler j'ai fait toutes
sortes de métiers que les jeunes
malheureusement j'ai pas l'impression
que j'ai envie de faire j'ai gardé les
vaches j'ai péché à Zarzis
de garder des vaches
j'ai plus personne de garder les vaches
je vais vous dire
c'est pas si mal que ça le garder les
vaches ça sent bon les vaches
on dort dans les étables avec une bonne
odeur de bien chaude non non
il y a un problème ils veulent plus
garder les vaches
je suis tellement libérée de mon avenir
c'est pas comme si agréable de plus
avoir d'avenir mais c'est merveilleux on
n'est pas là à ce que c'est creuser la
tête pour savoir ce qu'on va être demain
non non soyez je je fais des choses
comme si comme ça mais j'ai rien à
vendre j'ai rien besoin j'ai non vous
dites qu'il y a souvent des producteurs
qui vous disent je vais vous produire
moi un peu là que je vais vous je vais
vous faire une émission de télé vous
leur dit ça marchera pas et les mecs
partent avec plein d'entrains et puis en
général effectivement il revient au bout
d'un moment les projets n'ont pas été
acceptés plus personne va vous donner
une émission de télévision n'ont pas de
réponse dans ces cas-là ça reste dans
les tiroirs non quand mon nom apparaît
les projets se casse la gueule c'est un
producteur qui m'écoute si vous voulez
réussir dans votre carrière à la télé ne
me mettez pas dans votre projet ça c'est
pour finir je vais vous faire une
proposition
public
chaque fois que vous aurez quelque chose
à dire
vous pourrez venir le dire dans cette
émission d'accord vous êtes maso vous
voulez vraiment qu'on vous supprime
votre émission moi je crois la liberté
vous êtes encore très jeunes merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu